I consider it my personal quest to not
only empower you with the knowledge
you're gonna need to have a fulfilling
life but also a fulfilling love life
with that in mind welcome to the first
ever installment of mad hats guide to
finding the one Lord of the Ring Edition
hey girl was your face forged by Sauron
because you're precious what don't
respect oscar-winning CGI technology
that's fine fine whatever
you must be Frodo Baggins because I'm
the one and you've got me wrapped around
your finger the more accurate because he
just disappeared oh hey there you shall
not pass without giving me those digits
I mean and she jumped off the bridge
maybe I should just stick to theories
[Music]
hello Internet welcome to film theory
where today we're donning our mining
hats and delving too greedily and too
deep into the theory mines in order to
unearth the answer to the biggest
question of the Lord of the Rings no not
why the Hobbit movies were so bad not
even I have the answers to everything no
today I am delivering the definitive
answer to the Internet's favorite Lord
of the Rings theory why did Frodo just
ride the Eagles to Mount Doom and drop
the ring in we all know they exist we
know they can pretty much go anywhere we
know they're friendly to the ringbearer
side so why the heck did team ring just
ride up to Mordor Motor bra hmm
sorry Mordor in the first place honestly
it's like the movie is begging us to ask
this question 85 minutes and 48 seconds
into the very first movie if you're
watching the extended edition which is
there any other way to watch these
movies we see Gandalf GTF out of
Isengard on the back of a giant eagle
after sending them off to go get it for
him like some sort of high fantasy uber
why else introduce the perfect solution
to every problem so early just hit up
your mouth app calling eagle and we got
this whole trilogy wrapped up in a cool
well the 42 one of the most famous and
most popular fan theories of all time
this wasn't the plot hole at all the
plan was to use the Eagles to fly to
Mordor all along it's a great theory
really and if film theory existed back
in 2001 I'd be all over this one like a
horde of orcs on this other work that
they just decided to randomly
cannibalize pointing to the fly you
fools theory it was made popular by an
infographic from the website tickled
which miraculously isn't a porn site go
figure
Haymitch spread quickly and the full
theory was proposed by reddit user
Vulcan death grip which you know clap
half right out of the gate for the
amazing user name to sum it up here's
the theory our hero wizard Gandalf is
imprisoned by the evil wizard
Saruman for failing to join his evil
master plan gandalf orders up a giant
eagle lifts on his smart moth and boom
Giant Eagle arrives and zooms Gandalf
away but instead of heading straight to
Rivendell to meet Frodo and the rest of
the fellowship the theory
that Gandalf instead flies to the Eagles
Eyrie which is a real canonical thing
established in middle-earth to talk with
the king of the Eagles the Eyrie is
actually pretty close to Rivendell but
it's on the eastern side of the Misty
Mountains a detail that's important
because when Gandalf is escaping on the
Eagle we actually see him veer east over
the mountains to the directions with
this theory actually match up once there
Gandalf according to the theory hatches
a plan to use the Eagles to fly the ring
to Mordor something we never see or hear
any word of in the books or movies
Gandalf in the Eagles decide to keep
this plan a secret because they need to
retain the element of surprise even
retaining that surprise from all the
readers and viewers
apparently so now the question becomes
where to meet up with the Eagles for
maximum secrecy Gandalf decides they
should meet up in the South because
canonically all the other areas are
overrun with either orcs or agents of
Sauron and they have to meet on this
side of the Misty Mountains because
again according to the theory the
weather in the mountains is too
dangerous for the Eagles to fly over
that might seem like a bit of a stretch
but the story does happen in winter in
the mountains and Lord of the Rings were
modeled after the European Alps where
it's literally like minus 46 degrees in
the winter so it's plausible to say the
least the only other option for the trip
would have been to avoid the Misty
Mountains entirely and go all the way
south to the gap of Rohan but as
literally everyone tells Boromir every
time he brings it up this is right next
to Isengard
aka Saruman's base of operations meaning
all the Eagles would get spotted
immediately and the plan is busted so
left with no other options they decide
to got to travel on foot to the other
side of the mountains meet the Eagles
and then finally fly to Mordor into the
south unfortunately the group can't make
it over the mountains due to you know
that afro mentioned nasty weather and
the fellowship decides to go for no shut
up Boromir stop suggesting it they go
through the mines of Moria
where Pippin literally gets Gandalf
killed because he is the worst but right
before Gandalf falls he utters these
three fateful words foolish according to
the theory this was Gandalf telling the
Fellowship what they were supposed to do
fly using the Eagles but go figure team
ring is too thick to get it honestly
though who can blame him instead of
using two of his last three remaining
words to insult his team Gandalf could
have made things a bit more explicit
instead of fly you fools he could have
said it fly to Mordor fly using Eagles
even something as simple as fly I liken
and I'm sure everyone could have figured
out the rest so anyway that's the theory
and honestly I think it's a really cool
theory the problem is it's just wrong
you take it from me I know a thing or
two about wrong theories that's right
for once in my life I'm giving myself an
early Christmas present and I get to
poke holes into someone else's theory
Wow how cathartic to turn the tables for
a change today I'm gonna shoot down the
Eagle Fury pun definitely intended
because it is literally the worst
strategy for the fellowship ever
honestly it's almost worse than just
straight-up giving the ring to Sauron
and doing this theory I can just rely on
old reddit posts from 2012 oh no I went
digging I busted out the Lord of the
Rings books I got The Silmarillion I
pored over the letters Pole King wrote
to pretty much everybody I picked up two
unfinished tales in the collection of
books that are compiled by Christopher
Tolkien JR arse editor map trader and
publisher books filled with partial
stories and scraps of lore I spent days
poring over tens of thousands of pages
and not a book pages mind you literal
physical actual paper pages because
Christopher Tolkien is some sort of
technophobe that won't allow the more
obscure nerdy titles to be published an
electronic format so out the window in
my control f function and in the window
with my analog control F function which
is just an index and let me just say it
those things suck
and one more disclaimer here because I
know that some people don't consider the
unfinished tales and letters to be can
because it's that kinda fanbase so I
only went with those sources insofar as
they didn't contradict anything in the
actual books if there was ever a
disagreement
I always defaulted to the information
that was actually published and what did
I learn from doing all that well that
the lore of middle-earth is really long
and sometimes really dry and glosses
over some big things like the
destruction of an entire continent that
gets explained away in a whopping one
paragraph so the first thing to know is
that in Tolkien's Laura most of the
stuff in middle-earth was created by
three gods Conway Yavana and owl a yes
Miller has gods gods that let's be
honest we're probably a bit pissed at a
three Hobbit movies scraping the
absolute bottom of the barrel for any
content to fill their excessive runtimes
they still didn't make the cut anyway
it'd be yvonna created all the plants
trees forests and animals all a comes in
and makes the dwarves Yavana
worried that the dwarves would literally
just mow down the forests to make stuff
creates the ends to protect the trees
maaan way feeling a bit left out sees
the stuff the other two are creating it
goes ah sweet would you help me make
some Eagles like big ones big Eagles and
boom yvonna and mod way made the Eagles
and thus the Eagles came into existence
the end now why would you care about any
of this stuff well it shows us that the
Eagles go super far back in the history
of this world and in general the older
stuff is in middle-earth the more
powerful it is except for the dwarves
sorry Gimli but that means in the
hierarchy of middle-earth Eagles rank
way up there the gods or Valar as there
are at the top directly below them or
the demigods or my are this tier has
some familiar faces Sauron Arlen and
Kendall and the Eagles are just slightly
below them in fact Tolkien himself as a
bit wishy-washy on this point saying
that hey the Eagles are pretty much
unofficially Meyer but anyways suffice
it to say they rank above all the other
races so why does any of this matter
well canonically and this is a point
that the movies don't really do a good
job of explaining the Ring of Power
works proportionally to the power of the
holder you ever wonder why a hobbit was
really the safest choice to be ring
bearer why this all-powerful ring that
everyone
so scared of only manages to turn people
in missile it's because hobbyists are a
really low power race in this world and
because of that the Ring of Power is the
least dangerous in their hands the One
Ring can only really use what's he in
the wearer which isn't that much when
it's being carried by a hobbit now
contrast that to the giant Eagles who
are practically demigods and who
according to Tolkien himself have a
wingspan of 30 pound putting them and
half the size of a football field and
they're not just big during the war of
Wrath which was a huge war before the
Lord of the Rings series happened they
were able to kill the dragon that was so
enormous that when he crash-landed he
collapsed three giant active volcanoes
these Eagles are massive powerful and
they're immortals who are more powerful
than all the other races on middle-earth
oh yeah and they can also canonically
see through walls the Eagles are more
than just mere Birds they are no joke
and they definitely don't need their
power amped up by the One Ring if you
give the Eagles an opportunity to carry
the One Ring you're looking at
potentially the most powerful Dark Lords
in the entire series if they can manage
to fit the ring on their talons that is
if you think about it this is the same
reason why the ring has to stay out of
everyone else's hands this is why
Gandalf never directly touches the ring
and tries to keep it out of his sight as
much as possible even telling Frodo that
through him it would yield upon great a
terrible Doernbecher because Gandalf is
a Meyer demigod the classic Galadriel
freakout scene is her basically
predicting her own power amped up on the
ring which is again why so many people
are required to protect the darn thing
hey hey
Boromir my eyes are up here hey also
notice when the Eagles do come into play
to rescue Sam and Frodo from Mount Doom
as it collapses when the ring of power
is no longer around as soon as it's
destroyed and out of the running then
it's safe to bring the Eagles in because
they're no longer gonna be tempted no
one's at risk and that's exactly when
Gandalf calls for their help again but
there's more to this plan being stupid
than just raw power
Sauron literally doesn't comprehend the
possibility that anyone with the ring
would want to destroy it he doesn't
discover this plan until mere moments
before the ring is tossed into the heat
of Mount Doom he can't defend himself if
he doesn't know what he's defend
against that's why it's imperative that
the fellowship remain a secret from
everyone and the Eagles remember they're
the size of Boeing 747s up there trying
to conduct a stealth mission with a
giant eagle to drop the ring into the
pits of Mount Doom would be like trying
to sneak into a Jamba Juice with a
fighter jet or you know what maybe we
should just believe Tolkien himself in a
letter from June 1958 where he
criticizes an unofficial Lord of the
Rings film treatment sent to him going
so far as to say it's murdered his story
yeah that's harsh feedback Tolkien
directly comments on the scripts overuse
of the Eagles quote the Eagles are a
dangerous machine I've used them
sparingly and that is the absolute limit
of their credibility end quote
using the Eagles to solve all your
problems just doesn't make for a good
story and that's ultimately what we as
an audience are here for and Tolkien's
being the incredible writer that he is
knew just that but hey that's just a
theory
a film theory and cut man finding
loopholes in theories is fun and
cathartic maybe I should just changed
this channel to be the theory buster
[Music]